[Musique]
c'est un événement qui rassemble des
sportifs de haut niveau et des chefs
cuisiniers donc voilà pour les amoureux
des enfants pour SOS gazelle du sport et
et les
gourmands la compète de golf en scrumble
à 4 donc une formule sympathique par
équipe à 11h ils sont partis pour 5 he
de de rigolade de jeux avec l'esprit
compétition puisquil y a toujours ce
titre de champion des champions et à 16h
le concours Top Chef gourmand donc les
18 équipes de sportifs sont à table avec
leur toc et leur tablier et ils vont
composer les apero food et les
accompagnements du dîner avec évidemment
un jury de chef qui
sera sans pitié des grands
chefs notre programme depuis 3 ans pour
les enfants c'est vers Paris 2024
c'est-à-dire que depuis 3 ans on suit
les enfants pour les emmener à
l'esprit du sport mais du sport aussi
qui apporte des valeurs humaines parce
que tous les enfants ne peuvent pas être
des Champions mais l'exemple des
Champions est extraordinaire les enfants
viennent des
Eveline le matin et ensuite il y aura
euh 3 classes de 30 élèves donc 90
[Musique]
enfants